I was cooking eggs earlier with Calvin
it was a beautiful thing
I woke up and he ate four muffins my
nanny gave him four muffins
uh four little muffins you know and they
count that my wife counts that as uh
breakfast by the way when I count that
as a dessert but so I'm like did he eat
well and she's like yeah he ate
breakfast and then later on I'll find
out that he just ate like four muffins
and some gummy bears which is fine I
mean he needs calories and you know his
thing is eating a lot of people's dad
you know a lot of people's sons and and
[__] and daughters or children whatever
they have like the thing where it's like
they're not smart or they're not you
know
active or they're not this mine is my
son is just like oh dude you think I
need to eat [__] off oh you think I need
to eat huh no I don't and he'll just
hold out for those Gummy Bears or
Jujubes or some [__] dude the other day
he was he came up to me and he had these
gummy bears and I don't even know by the
way he gets in the pantry come I hear
this is what this is why I know I'm
[__] by the way this is why I know
it's gonna be a tough day for my son
eating I'm watching TV and I hear from
the kitchen
and I'm like
I'm [__]
he comes up with a little bag of Gummy
Bears which by the way I don't know who
got them I said to my wife I said where
do we get these and she says I have no
idea oh they just appear
that's how good uh General Mills is
or whatever whoever is Little Debbie
snacks I don't know and um
and he says can I have this Dad and I
said buddy you didn't eat breakfast I I
I don't know if you should eat these you
can have a few because I'm sucker right
sucker Central and and my son goes like
this
more and more and more and more and more
and more I want 10 of them
and I laughed dude and I said Calvin you
have to eat actual food and he starts
crying and I [__] don't give it to
him I was like we can't eat these dude
we gotta eat an actual real food Okay so
then he grabs the bag brings it over to
my nanny and or his Nanny and says
can I have these and she's like your dad
said you need to eat real food that's a
dessert food you need to eat real food
and then
he cries brings them back puts them down
then
[__]
I go to do uh Lifeline the other podcast
here on super good on the super good
Channel
I come back my parents are over they
said they were gonna come over they're
gonna come over to hang out with Calvin
okay I'm chilling for a little bit
my son is in the other room and my my
grandpa his grandpa is in the other room
Calvin comes back eating the [__]
gummy bears and I say what where'd you
get those and he says pop pop my dad
comes in and my mom's like oh papa is a
sucker
I guess that's what grandpas are
supposed to do and it was cute
so then today I was like I gotta get
some actual real food in them and I made
we made eggs we made eggs and it was a
beautiful thing he loved stirring it and
then I was giving him eggs and he goes
like and I and I said you like them we
made good eggs huh and he said yes we
did and it was so freaking cute dude
[Music]